well previous board trustees are
reacting to the news of the
superintendent being ousted joe moeller
continues our team coverage with more
joe and the trustees we spoke to say
they are heartbroken over what has
unfolded and are worrying about the
students and educators now
we caught up with former trustee terry
janison earlier today she spent five
years as a school board trustee she
thinks dr jarrah has done a decent job
considering the circumstances she has
been watching the turmoil and is
saddened that the trustees and
superintendent couldn't work together
what i've been seeing
is just really
sad for
number one our children
but number two our community i just
believe that the behavior of the school
board specifically has been so
disappointing
and i just think it reflects badly on
the entire clark county she is worried
there won't be a superintendent that
will want to come work for the district
she hopes the trustees and the district
can overcome this i hope they all figure
out what their jobs are as trustees and
then what their jobs are as officers
because it's very specific
we also spoke to sheila molten who was a
trustee for 12 years we'll have much
more on what she has to say coming up
here at five reporting in the studio joe
muller live local now